it's feminism tells you you don't you
don't need a man but we do
we're a girl i don't discriminate you
know
i mean
but um
all human we need love we are you know
into that like we are yeah i think i
think human beings like human beings
need companionship yeah do you know what
i mean like um we currently live in a
time where you know whether you've been
on social media or not like it seems to
be like this gender war going on do you
know what i mean and it's like men hate
women women hate men blah blah blah and
it's like essentially that is only going
to lead to more loneliness essentially
do you know what i mean and it's just
like if you don't if you're not able to
find some kind of middle ground as men
and women then you're just all going to
be lonely you get to be all going to be
lonely and hateful like come on guys
like we need to kind of find some kind
of middle ground you know what i mean
and i i just think that um
yeah i think i think men are actually in
this society they're quite upset about
feminism because feminism has taken on a
very aggressive stance he's taken on a
very aggressive like
sorry girl did you know that even first
wave feminism was aggressive like even
the earliest
like forms of feminism was aggressive
but then it needed to be what i think
first wave feminism maybe it needed to
be aggressive i don't know there was
like bomb threats well not not that
aggressive
not that aggressive there was like um
i i can't remember off the top of my
head but rolo tomasi talks a lot about
it like even first wave feminism always
was aggressive and had a disdain towards
men
like i think feminism has always been a
gender war
i i i i wouldn't disagree with you
because even even if we talk about the
right to vote like they act like it was
men against women but it wasn't women if
you voted you were part of the draft
who's trying to be part of the draft not
me
if i had to give up today that's
equality you gotta go out there and grab
a gun and start shooting what are you
talking about nope i don't want any
quality in there
if if voting today had to come with the
draft i'm i'm a scaredy cat i don't do
that but the thing is that's very
interesting because feminism uh is
essentially women say and i don't
generally believe them they say it's
about equality but then about equality
in in what form like i said if there was
a war to break out tomorrow
are you saying that the army should be
half women and half men most women do
not want to um go out and fight in a war
right men understand that there may be
their duty to protect their country
their children their wives the women of
the country and that is one of the
things that um
a lot of women don't take into
consideration men do some of the stuff
that women just don't want to do
goes both ways
i'm saying the thing is we're talking
about how how it what it takes to build
an actual society and keep it running
men understand there is a duty to keep
the society running this house was
probably built by men this this camera
scaffolding the irrigation systems
plumbing all of this stuff men
understand that this has to make society
run but to transform a house to a home
it's a woman right but we're not talking
about that we're not talking about the
thing is to make a home just to make a
home you need a house yeah to make it
home so you're talking about the after
the you're talking about aftercare
nobody
okay so if okay so okay so
at least 90 to 95 percent of bricklayers
are men
yeah the people that build houses
are men now women have the opportunity
to be bricklayer bricklayers but they're
not choosing to be bricklayers why
it's nature as men exactly so we so
exactly so that's what i'm saying so no
i'm not blaming anyone i'm saying if you
understand that men have to take the
dirty grueling dusty jobs right to get
the society done then really and truly
you ain't got nothing to complain about
because without the dirty grueling dusty
jobs that we do you wouldn't even have a
house to live in
but everyone's asking the men to take
those jobs no we do no it's not you
asking us we understand we it has to be
done that's on the menu all right so
then you want to live in the wilderness
sure yeah
i don't want to pay rent
oh
my god all right so go live in the
wilderness then
we'll know don't live in go live
no you're choosing not to it's it's very
possible not really yes it is if you get
it if you get a van if you get a van
i've seen a lot of i don't have a
driving license
can get a tent though
go camping never come but your driving
instructor is most likely going to be a
man
because he understand that society is
going to need to drive
that's not like men have this inbuilt
thing of
um whether it be conscious or
subconscious that the society that they
live in needs to be pushed forward okay
they can't just
sit around looking at dresses right i'm
not being disrespectful but i can't sit
around on bloody asos or pretty little
things looking at dresses and looking
i'm just saying that we we're not like
oh yeah whimsical stuff yeah let's
manifest everything men are like listen
[ __ ] has to get done around here for
society to move and the thing is
a lot of the time men feel
a lot of this is what men are feeding
now and i think it's a lot of the time
the reason for like the the ism and
schism between men and women men are
like but hang on we built this [ __ ]
like we like we built this like how are
you gonna hate us without
the internet
which was a male
built thing you would have been able to
talk on the internet about men and talk
[ __ ] well we don't hate you because you
are doing those jobs who's saying that
so
i'm not talking about you i'm saying but
i'm talking about feminism
and it's even like even in this
conversation like we always say oh well
that's not the men's like that's that's
the men's fault if they that happens
like it's like that disdain is it's not
it's not i love men
i know what we should like i'm not
saying that you don't i'm saying that
when it comes to feminism
feminism in these days and times seems
like it's like a um like it's against
men like men of this the patriarchy oh
my god misogyny but it's like listen
without patriarchy and misogyny you
wouldn't even have a house no to me
feminism is like if a man goes and has
sex with 10 women you know he's cool but
if a woman does that she's a [ __ ]
that's what feminism is to me it should
you know this should both be cool they
should both be [ __ ] the reason why
but the biology doesn't support you
right so that's what i'm saying like if
we're about feminism do you think it's
fair that we should give the facts to
younger women and say hey if you sleep
with more men your chance of a happy
marriage goes down drastically yeah
women should have all the statistics i
don't know that was a statistic like i
don't know that was a fact yeah
and and this is what i'm saying like
like the men and women are different
and men and men don't have that same
thing like men if they sleep with more
women they're happier